we begin in Washington where the stage
is set for president Trump's historic
impeachment trial Chief Justice John
Roberts and Senators who will serve as
jurors were sworn in yesterday this is
only the third time that has ever
happened for a president meanwhile mr.
Trump insisted he does not know --left
artists who worked with the president's
personal attorney Rudy Giuliani Partners
who faces unrelated federal charges now
claims more of the president's aides
knew about efforts to pressure Ukraine
to investigate political foes Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy good
morning what happens next well the trial
resumes in the Senate on Tuesday and
Senators are gonna have to figure out at
some point how to handle all this new
information Republicans say it shows
that the House didn't do its due
diligence while Democrats say it shows
that the White House is still covering
up the truth do you solemnly swear Chief
Justice John Roberts administered a more
than 200 year old oath of impartiality
to nearly all 100 senators you will do
impartial justice according to the
Constitution and laws
so help you God hours before the
senators signed their names one by one
in an oath book the Government
Accountability Office a nonpartisan
federal watchdog agency found that the
president violated the law when he
withheld more than two hundred million
dollars in military aid to Ukraine
the GAO stated that the law does not
permit the president to substitute his
own policy priorities for those that
Congress has enacted into law
forty-five years here I have never seen
anything like this new evidence
continues to emerge about the effort to
pressure Ukraine to announce an
investigation into the Biden's I should
be their number one witness because I'm
the one that got all the dirt the new
allegations come from former Trump donor
and indicted businessman Lev Parnas who
says he was the man president Trump and
his personal attorney Rudy Giuliani and
trusted with getting Ukraine to announce
the investigation in a series of
interviews Parnas says many top White
House officials were involved or aware
of what was going on everybody there
quote was close to Trump know that this
was a thorn in the side and this was a
serious situation both Bolton vania
vania Bolton I don't think agreed with
it
president Trump has repeatedly denied
even knowing Parnas I don't know him at
all don't know what he's about don't
know where he comes from know nothing
about him harnesses lawyer responded
with this video of his client with mr.
Trump at mar-a-lago back in 2016
every time he says I'll show them
another picture harness has already
released several photos with the rest of
the president's family people questioned
both sides note that Parnas has
credibility issues this is an example of
all of the president's henchmen but
Democrats say the new evidence is all
the more reason to hear from the
witnesses they request it in America
trials have evidence and cover-ups do
not Senate Republicans say it's not
their job to reinvestigate the case the
job is to respond to what we've been
given in the case that was built by the
house the White House acknowledges that
Parnassus allegations make things in
their words messy but they insist that
the outcome of the trial won't change it
would take for Senate Republicans to
agree with all Democrats to bring new
witness testimony into this trial and
last night one Republican senator Susan
Collins of Maine said Tony that she is
likely to support that Alright messy is
one word for it Nancy thank you very
much